I was born in flea bottom your blood is
Noble
you saying my father he was some Lord or
yeah
your father's house
just a bastard
the bastard of Robert of the house
Baratheon
first of his name king of the Andals in
the first man why do you think the gold
cloaks wanted you
there is power in King's blood
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns season 8
prediction video in today's video I
wanted to talk about ginjury and what
his purpose may be now that they brought
this character back after he was gone
for so many seasons but before I start
talking about that I just want to remind
everyone about the giveaway
Game of Thrones Season 7 comes out on
blu-ray and DVD in just a few weeks and
I wanted to give a few copies away just
to show my appreciation for those of you
that continue to watch my videos I will
be giving two copies away so that means
two of you will be picked randomly all
you need to do to enter is click the
giveaway link that is done in the
description of this video there are
several ways to enter through that link
which will increase your chances of
winning the first winner will be picked
in about a week or so so make sure you
enter soon good luck to everyone who is
participating now let's begin like I
said at the beginning of this video I
want to talk about gun jury and a few of
the different reasons why I think they
may have brought this character back
into the main plot in my opinion I feel
like they kept this character alive all
these years for a reason Gendry has
escaped death so many times throughout
the course of this series it makes me
believe he has a purpose to serve in the
eighth and final season I actually want
to go over some of the times he avoided
death because it's easy to forget some
of them and I am sure I will forget some
instances myself but people have been
trying to kill ginjury ever since season
1 after his father King Robert Baratheon
died Gendry had to flee King's Landing
or else he would have been killed with
all of Robert's other bastards
luckily for Gendry his mentor topham
aunt had a feeling this would happen so
he made Gendry leave the shop or he was
a blacksmith and this was one ginjury
joined up with the Nights Watch and he
was able to sneak out of the city with
urine and Arya Stark that was
technically the first time Gendry
avoided death and his second time came
shortly after that while he and Arya
travelled to the wall the city watch
came looking for Gentry again but at
this time Gendry had no idea why he just
knew it couldn't be for anything good
but Joran risked his own life and made
sure the city watch didn't take any of
his recruits
even though Joran was able to get the
city watch to leave and only bought them
a little bit of time
because they had every intention of
returning but this time they weren't
going to leave without ginjury dead or
alive
sure enough the gold cloaks returned but
this time they had Lannister men with
them they pretty much killed yarn
immediately which put ginjury in a very
vulnerable position because he was his
only real protection but thankfully Arya
convinced them that law me was ginjury
because ginjuries bullhead helmet was
laying right next to his dead body but
they still took Arya and Gendry as
prisoners anyway ginjury may have
escaped death again but now he was taken
as a prisoner to Harrenhal and he wasn't
at Harrenhal long before he almost died
again
Gendry was picked out of the crowd to be
tortured by the tickler and he would
have died but thankfully Tywin Lannister
showed up and put an end to it because
Tywin knew the prisoners could be put to
good use of course this was when Arya
became Tywin's cup bearer and ginjuries
started making weapons for them and
shortly after all of this this was when
Aria had Jagan agar start to kill some
of her enemies there and help them
escape before they were all executed
since Tywin left and could no longer
protect them and Oreo was right because
after jagan helps them escape sure
enough everyone at Harrenhal was
slaughtered after they escaped Harrenhal
they eventually run into the Brotherhood
without banners and this was when Gendry
decided he was going to stay with them
and make weapons at least that was until
Melisandre showed up and took ginjury
away because she wanted to use him as a
sacrifice to help Stannis win the war
and ultimately become the king of the
Seven Kingdoms so as you can see Gendry
was constantly on the verge of death and
someone was constantly saving him from
being killed even while he was with
Melisandre she ended up using some of
his blood but before she could do the
ultimate sacrifice with him Davos helped
him escape in the middle of the night by
sending him off on a boat from
Dragonstone Davos only gave him a little
bit of food and water and Gendry did not
know how to swim so for all we knew
Gendry could have been dead he had
disappeared for so many seasons it
seemed like his story may be done but
when you escaped death that many times
you have to have some bigger purpose in
terms of the endgame in the television
show Gendry is the last living character
with Baratheon blood and this makes him
very important
in my opinion in order to keep one of
the major houses from going extinct they
need Gendry and this is one of the many
reasons why I think they brought him
back in season seven Gendry makes his
triumphant return and we learned that he
was in King's Landing the entire time
exactly where the people are that won
him dead the most Joffrey may have been
the one who ordered all of Roberts
bastards to be killed but I still don't
think Cersei would want Gendry running
around with any kind of claim either
even though he is a bastard but he can
easily be legitimized which I think will
happen before the series ends even after
Gendry came back in season seven he
could have been killed again north of
the wall he may not have been up there
for the main battle but they could have
kept him there and killed his character
off if they had no plans for him in the
eighth season but once again
Gendry survives another season and now
that season 8 filming has begun you have
to wonder what will they use Gendry for
in the final six episodes ginjury has
already been spotted in belfast this
week so we will definitely see him in
the next season but the question remains
why why did they bring this minor
character back is it just purely
fanservice at this point because of how
popular his rowing mean became or is
there something more personally I think
there are a few reasons and one of the
more obvious reasons is because Gendry
knows how to make weapons really well
you're more than they can ever be
they're just foot soldiers in a great
you will make Kings rise
we all know that the Great War is upon
us especially now that the night king
and his army are south of the wall
luckily John was able to get enough
dragonglass to equip the entire north
with weapons and Gendry is the perfect
candidate to help make those weapons out
of dragonglass this was actually the
main reason why Davos went the fine
ginjury in King's Landing Davos told
ginjury he was going to have him sent to
Winterfell to make weapons but as we all
know Gendry told John exactly who he was
Gendry didn't just want to make weapons
he wanted to go on the adventure north
of the wall as well so he volunteered to
go but now that the mission is over I
can only assume
Gendry will fulfill there are other
needs which is making weapons something
Gendry excels at doing there is also a
good chance ginjury knows how to work
with Valyrian steel now I know some
people don't believe this to be true but
I disagree
gendry's mentor topo moth was one of the
best blacksmiths in all of King's
Landing and he learned how to reforge
Valyrian steel when he was in volantis
which is exactly where Melisandre is
going in the books it was actually
taught home aunt who reforged ice into
what owes well and Oathkeeper for Tywin
Lannister
I think top Oman may have shown Gendry
how to do this too even though there is
no evidence of this yet but this could
be a big reveal that they are saving for
the a season you have to think george RR
martin made Gendry a blacksmith for a
specific reason and i don't think it's
just a coincidence Gendry worked for the
one man in King's Landing who knew how
to rework Valyrian steel there must be
another reason why those two worked
together
personally I think it would be amazing
if Gendry meets some Valyrian steel
weapons for the war I know they have
plenty of dragonglass right now but
let's be honest sword fights are so much
cooler to watch using daggers sucks Plus
Samwell Tarly took a bunch of books and
documents from the Citadel when he left
in the middle of the night perhaps the
hidden method of making Valyrian steel
was written on one of those pages Sam
has with him Sam may discover the method
or ingredients in Daenerys could provide
her dragons fire and ginjury could be
the blacksmith to make them this is one
of the reasons they may have brought
ginjury back in the next reason could be
Gendry making some kind of marriage
alliance or more specifically bring
two houses together this is something
Robert Baratheon always wanted the
Starks and Baratheon's to join houses we
were meant to rule together if your
sister had lived would have been bound
by blood well it's not too late I have a
son you have a daughter well join our
houses and as of right now the Starks
have two good candidates with Sansa and
Arya Sansa and Gendry are closer in age
but Aria in ginjury already have a very
strong relationship with one another the
only problem is aria always said she did
not want to settle down and become a
lady she did not see herself getting
married and having children but a lot of
kids say things like that and now that
aria is an adult and she has dealt with
so much death maybe her outlook when
this has changed
if Aria and Gendry are still alive after
the Great War ends she might be tired of
running and fighting and who knows when
she sees Gendry again Sparks might start
the fly
I think Oreo will be very happy to see
him again there is something from the
books that I want to read to you this
was actually in the very first book a
game of Thrones in one of Arya's very
first chapters she is was septum
ordained in Sansa and this is when they
are sewing together septum ordained was
going on and on about how well saunas
work was and she says Songza has
delicate hands but when septum or dane
talks about arias hands she says aria
has hands like a blacksmith I always
thought this was interesting and it made
me wonder if Aria and ginjury were meant
to hook up at the end of the story but
it might mean nothing I just figured I
would mentioned that maybe Dan and Dave
read that line too and thought they
would have them hook up eventually who
knows but that would be some crazy
foreshadowing if it did happen because I
believe that was written on the very
first page of arias first chapter if I'm
not mistaken
even if Gendry doesn't marry a stark I
still think he has a big purpose in the
end which will most likely take place
during the rebuilding phase of Westeros
after the big wars are over in a new
power structure is in place I think
Kendra will be one of the remaining
characters left who can help establish
the new way of living
and a new set of laws that will allow
all Seven Kingdoms to be independent
instead of ruled by one person sitting
on an iron throne I don't think they
will allow house Baratheon to go extinct
at least I hope not
someone will legitimize ginjury and give
him a portion of land to have they must
keep at least one person alive from each
major house and they will be some of the
people that can ensure Westeros can
thrive and flourish again a lot of
people are going to die in the last
season and most of Westeros is going to
be destroyed but there will be a group
of people that survive and I believe
ginjury will be one of those people this
is ultimately why they brought him back
for the final season Gendry will survive
and make sure that spring is not only a
dream but this is just my opinion let me
know why you think injury is back and
why he will be coming back for the a
season do you think they have bigger
plans for Gendry or do you think he will
die either way let me know your thoughts
down below I want to thank everyone for
watching the video I do appreciate you
taking a time out of your day I also
want to thank everyone for their
continued support on patreon it really
means a lot to me and I cannot thank you
enough I hope everyone has a great day
and hopefully I will see you come back
for the next one
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you